su médico puede llevar a cabo una
broncoscopía para buscar y diagnosticar
problemas dentro de sus pulmones su
nariz y boca son puntos de entrada para
que el aire ingrese y salga de sus
pulmones a través de su tráquea o tubo
aéreo y tubos bronquiales con cada
respiración sus pulmones inhalan oxígeno
y exhalan dióxido de carbono
este intercambio de gases es la forma en
que su cuerpo hace que su sangre se
oxígeno
una broncoscopía se puede realizar para
buscar y posiblemente recuperar un
objeto extraño que pudo haber sido
inhalado en lugar de haber sido ingerido
investigar una tos persistente o una tos
con expectoración de sangre obtener una
muestra de mucosidad tejido o líquido
del interior de sus pulmones o evaluar
una radiografía de tórax o tomografía
computarizada normal antes de someterse
al procedimiento recibirá un medicamento
para ayudarlo a relajarse y reducir la
tos se insertará una vía intravenosa
para administrar medicamentos
adicionales se controlará su corazón y
presión arterial y se le dará oxígeno
adicional durante el procedimiento
se le administrara anestesia local para
adormecer su garganta o anestesia
general
durante el procedimiento su médico
deslizará lentamente un broncoscopio a
través de su nariz o boca pasará por su
garganta cuerdas vocales tráquea hasta
llegar a sus tubos bronquiales el médico
examinará cuidadosamente las paredes de
sus vías respiratorias y posiblemente
tome muestras para un examen de
laboratorio o retire el objeto extraño
después del procedimiento será
trasladado a un área de recuperación si
se tomó una biopsia probablemente se le
tomará una radiografía de tórax
antes que abandona el hospital su médico
enviará toda muestra de mucosidad
líquido o biopsia que se extrajo de sus
pulmones a un laboratorio para ser
examinada los resultados deben estar
disponibles en una semana